hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir
kokosmakronen ich liebe kokosmakronen
ich hab dir schon gemacht da war ich
zwölf so einfach ist das rezept und ich
zeige euch jetzt die wenigen zutaten die
wir dafür benötigen und zwar sind das
natürlich kokosraspeln außerdem
puderzucker eiweiß und das ist optional
bittermandel aroma und wer es richtig
schön haben möchte nimmt noch runde
oblaten dazu es gibt verschiedene arten
kokosmakronen zuzubereiten ich zeig euch
natürlich die einfachste den lecker sind
wie alle und wir gehen jetzt in einen
ausreichenden großen topf die
kokosraspeln des puderzucker und auch
das eiweiß und gerne noch zwei bis drei
tropfen bittermandel aroma
[Musik]
und jetzt reden wir den topf inhalt
richtig gut um wichtig ist dass der herd
jetzt nur auf kleinster stufe ist denn
wir haben ja jetzt eiweiß da drin und
wir wollen ja nicht dass es später zur
wird also die niedrigste stufe nehmen
und dann alles gut und bis eine klebrige
masse erhaltet und nach ungefähr drei
bis vier minuten seid ja auch schon
fertig wer mit so eine schöne klebrige
masse erhalten und jetzt räumlich hier
kurz alles weg wo man backblech und dann
zeige ich euch wie ihr das ganze
fertigstellt und ich sehe jetzt meine
oblaten auf meinen mit backpapier
ausgelegtes backblech beziehungsweise
habe ich da ist eine dauer back folie
drauf und ihr könnt das ganze natürlich
auch ohne opladen machen aber so dass es
einfach schöner
und falls ihr das ohne oblaten macht
dann lass es einfach weg und erinnert
sich auch nichts am rezept und jetzt
nehme ich mir ein eis portionierer zur
hilfe es geht natürlich auch mit zwei
esslöffeln aber so wisst ihr immer genau
das auf jeder platte gleich viel von der
chorus masse drauf ist und jetzt einfach
auf die oblate geben noch ein bisschen
zurecht rücken und dann ist es fertig
[Musik]
die kokosmakronen sind jetzt fertig
vorbereitet ich habe insgesamt 20 stück
raus bekommen sind aber auch relativ
groß also wenn ihr kleinere oblaten habt
dann habt ihr natürlich mehr
kokosmakronen raus und ich gebe es jetzt
in den vorgeheizten backofen bei 150
grad ober unterhitze bisher außen
richtig schön goldbraun sind nach 20
minuten sind die macarons fertig außen
schön goldbraun und in richtig saftig
genauso wie es sein muss und ich mach
das jetzt gerne so dass es aber völlig
optional
ich habe jetzt hier noch ein bisschen
zeit peter kuvertüre geschmolzen in der
mikrowelle und gibt es jetzt nochmal der
körper dass könnt ihr ganz so machen wie
ihr möchtet ich persönlich liebe das
danach nahm sich das schön aus können
und dann sind sie fertig
[Musik]
und falls ihr genau solche kokos fans
seid wie ich dann macht die leckeren
kokosmakronen unbedingt nach ihr werdet
süchtig seit auf jeden fall gewarnt ich
könnte das ganze blech alleine essen die
genauen mengenangaben findet ihr hier
unten in der infobox
ansonsten könnt ihr meinen kanal gerne
kostenlos abonnieren einfach passt ja
auch nichts mehr
hinterlasst gerne ein bäumchen nach oben
und folgt uns auf instagram na seid ihr
immer auf dem aktuellsten stand und ich
sag bis zum nächsten mal auf rigi
sketchen tschüss
[Musik]